well hello to everyone participating
in our seminar my name is jim mccurry
i'm a senior applications chemist with
agilent technologies
in the wilmington delaware site in the
u.s today my topic is going to be
helium carrier gas for gc and gcms
conserving helium resources or
converting to hydrogen and nitrogen
so we'll be discussing both of these
topics for dealing with issues of helium
carrier gas
now the market situation with helium is
not something that's new
it seems to be an ongoing issue every
few years
and helium supplies are sometimes not
reliable
there can be outages occasionally and
also
prices can increase and that's prompted
customers to
look for alternatives to carrier gas
for gas chromatography using something
other than helium
we put together here a carrier gas
decision tree
i'm not going to go through it in detail
basically it
boils down to two things one is if you
need to continue to use
helium for your carrier gas particularly
if you're using say gcms methods
or if your sops will not allow you to
change
to an alternative carrier gas you do
have an option
and you can use helium conservation
however if you can take advantage of the
opportunity to change carrier gases
for your gc and gcms systems i'm going
to discuss
some of the approaches to migrating to
either hydrogen
or to nitrogen carrier gas for your
systems
so first let's discuss helium
conservation this is actually the
easiest thing to talk about
because this doesn't require any changes
or revalidation
of your methods because you'll continue
to use helium
as you always have so if you really
can't change or you don't want to change
the only choice you have dealing with
reduced supplies of helium or increasing
prices of helium
is to try to conserve it so there are a
number of approaches to helium
conservation
one of the most important ones does not
even deal with the instrument
or your methodologies it's in fact
looking at your infrastructure
and doing maintenance and lead checking
to be sure that you're delivering the
helium to the instruments that you need
without wasting it through leaks or
problems with the infrastructure
so what you want to do is monitor leaks
in your facility's helium delivery
system
at our site we have a central location
where the helium is stored and then it's
delivered throughout the building
through the various plumbings and
regulators that are
in the building's infrastructure this
actually can have the greatest impact on
helium savings
about seven or eight years ago we
noticed that
we were using a lot more helium than we
thought we should be using based on the
number of instruments
in the typical operating conditions in
our building
so the agilent gc division the people
who
maintain our site went on a search with
leak detectors
and found a number of leaks also
infrastructure tubing and things like
that that were getting old
and needed to be changed and upgraded
and by
fixing these infrastructure problems
we're actually able to reduce our helium
consumption by 50 percent
so this is actually a huge improvement
uh with the use of helium in the
building
it probably represents the the major
impact that you can have
in your facility another approach
that i've seen taken by some customers
is actually turn
off the system during idle time
so it's not running at all everything is
cooled down and physically turned off
however this really isn't recommended uh
for many gcs and really not recommended
for gcms
because of the need to maintain vacuum
in the mass spectrometer
turning the system off and cooling it
down is really bad for
a number of gc columns and traps air can
diffuse into the columns causing
oxidation
and a lot of the traps or specialty pack
columns that
are used in some industries are damaged
by air
and by heating and cooling by turning
the system on and off
so we want to try to avoid that and
that's not really the best approach to
conserving helium
so if you fixed all your infrastructure
issues and you want to now
try to minimize the amount of helium
being used by your methods
we're going to provide a solution for
that
with a helium conservation module for
the gas
chromatograph we actually introduced for
the 70
90 gc a number of years ago the first
generation helium conservation module
and this was based on a standard three
channel aux
epc system that was modified
to be able to conserve helium
and to switch to nitrogen as a standby
gas during idle time
since the introduction of the 80 8890
and the 8860
we have improved and updated that to the
next generation or second generation
helium conservation module to work with
our new gc platforms
the way this works is it automatically
switches the carrier gas supply
in the instrument to nitrogen during
standby time or idle time of the
instrument
so you're not actually collecting data
the helium is turned off and
nitrogen is automatically substituted
for that maintains an inert flow path
you can keep everything hot and this
will
save a lot of helium in your system
we can also automate that with our open
lab cds
data systems because we have sleep and
awake methods
that are standardized in the the
instruments
and in the cbs so the sleep method would
be one where nitrogen
is used during idle times and the awake
method is where you would switch back
from nitrogen
to helium with an awake method that
would
bring everything back up to operating
condition
and then purge out the nitrogen
that was used for the the sleep period
with helium
now we can combine this with gas saver
mode
that has been built into agilent's gc
since the
68 90 days and these
gas saver mode combined with the helium
conservation module
will give you the greatest reduction in
helium consumption
so a gas saver mode is used with our gc
inlets
particularly our split split list or
multi-mode inlet
and what this will do is for high split
flow methods
you'll have that initial high split flow
of helium
during the time of injection and then
after the
uh the sample has passed from the inlet
to the column
and the split has been achieved then the
split flow is reduced to a maintenance
level at a lower flow rate to save
helium
so let's take a look at the next
generation of helium conservation module
and see how it's configured and how it
actually works
so i'm showing here our two
configuration examples
now you can think of the helium
conservation module as a programmable
gas delivery man
middle band that's built into the 8890
or the 8860
so the helium conservation module is
just another type of epc
so it's put into the uh the back of the
gc
with the other epc units however
we don't plug our carrier gas now to the
other epcs
we simply plug the supply line of the
helium
into the helium conservation module and
then we also
plumb into that a nitrogen supply
so those are the two inlets into the
helium conservation module either
both helium and nitrogen and then
there's one column
common outlet and this is what's used to
deliver
the appropriate gas to the various
other epc modules in the system
so on the left hand diagram we're
looking at the back of the instrument
we can see our helium conservation
module so the outlet goes up to a t
and that t is plumbed to our front inlet
epc into the back inlet epc so
now the helium conservation module will
then
change the carrier gas supply to both of
those inlet modules
on the right hand diagram it's a
slightly more complicated
plumbing so again we have our helium
conservation
module where our two carrier gas
supplies come in
then we have our common outlet and then
rather going to a t we're going to
across
so this is going to deliver the
appropriate carrier gas when needed
either helium or nitrogen to both the
front and the back
inlet epcs and then if you have an
auxiliary
epc module like a pneumatic switching
device or psd or an
aux epc or a pcm
these auxiliary flows are often used as
secondary flows
for valve operations or for fluidic
switches
so the conservation module would also be
used to deliver
carrier gas to those auxiliary
systems
now we've seen how the helium
conservation switch is plumbed and set
up in the 8890 or 8860 gc
let's take a look at how it operates in
the sleep mode
and in the weight mode in the sleep mode
the channel controlling helium is turned
off
so this stops delivery of helium to the
other epc modules
plumbed to the helium conservation
switch
at the same time the epc channel that
has nitrogen plumbed to it
is turned on and nitrogen will flow from
the switch
to those other epc modules in this mode
helium is being conserved while nitrogen
is being used to maintain
an inert atmosphere throughout the gc
in the right hand diagram the opposite
is happening
this is in the wake mode so now the
nitrogen is turned off
and the helium is turned on so this
allows
helium to then flow through the module
and then be delivered to the various
epcs
there's another channel that i didn't
initially discuss and that's the third
channel
in the helium conservation switch and
this is the
purge channel the purge channel serves
an important function
particularly when going from the sleep
mode or nitrogen mode
to the helium mode in the
helium mode the purge channel allows
helium
to purge out all the nitrogen that has
been accumulated
in the module so that it doesn't leak
through and go to the other epcs
we want to make sure this doesn't happen
because nitrogen
can respond to some detectors like a
mass spec or
a tcd we want to make sure that there is
no residual nitrogen
in the system so this is typically how
we will use
the helium conservation switch to reduce
our helium consumption
while still allowing the instruments to
be turned on and hot
during the course of our operations
so now after we switch from our sleep to
our wake mode
where we're going from nitrogen to
helium as the carrier gas
the question becomes how long does it
take for all that nitrogen
in the system to purge out so that we're
actually ready to
operate our gc to do a sample analysis
and so we've done a study with using a
mass spectrometer and we found that
going from
the sleep to the wake mode if we wait 15
minutes
in the week mode this will allow the
helium
to remove all the residual nitrogen
throughout the entire flow path
and get back to an operating level of
nitrogen
with helium carrier gas so we see here
in the mass spectrometer within 15
minutes
we're now down to a low enough nitrogen
level
that we're able to pass the autotune if
you're using for instance a tcd
it actually takes a little bit longer
because the tcd is very sensitive to
nitrogen
and so i would recommend waiting for
between 15 or between 30 minutes and 60
minutes of purge
with the helium to remove all the
nitrogen
as i mentioned we can combine
our sleep and wake methodologies
that are built into our gcs and our data
systems
to actually set up a program to put the
system
in the sleep mode when we want to go
idle and use
nitrogen as the carrier gas and then
automatically turn on
say an hour or so before we come into
the laboratory
to go into the wake mode to purge out
the nitrogen
with helium and assure that we're ready
to run when we get to the laboratory
and this can be set up in a program way
much like a thermostat in your house can
be programmed
so i know in our house we have a
thermostat and during the day
when we're not home i have a program to
let the house temperature cool down to
save on
energy for heating the house and then a
half hour or so before we come home
the thermostat automatically turns on
and then warms the house up
and then opposite in the summertime with
heating and cooling
so the same thing can be done with the
sleek wake mode
you have a program built into the system
of the cds or to the
the firmware in the instrument to set
sleep and wait times to invoke those two
methods
so you can set this up in a very simple
and straightforward mode
to automate going from the sleep and
wake cycles
okay so the question now becomes how
much helium can i save
uh using the helium conservation switch
and the sleep weight methods that i've
just described
there's really no one answer for this it
really depends
on the method that you're running so how
much carrier gas the method uses
then often also how often you're running
that method
during the day so we put together a
helium savings calculator and what this
allows us to do
is put in the operating conditions for a
particular method
and then also uh the size of gas
cylinders that we're using if we're
delivering our gas to the instrument
with uh with cylinders
and then also what the cost of the uh
the cylinder cost is and then
and for using the nitrogen mode
uh the nitrogen cost so you can see with
this calculator
if we're not doing anything there's no
conservation
using this astm method d4815 which
measures
oxygenase and gasoline this is a
two-dimensional gc method so there's
actually
auxiliary flow in this method as well
you can see that with no conservation
a typical cylinder will last about 71
days
and so the yearly costs for operating
this
method for
basically one shift a day is about
fifteen hundred and thirty seven dollars
using
the helium costs that we're currently
invoking at our laboratory
now if you would use the conservation
switch
along with the gas saver mode
you can see that we can reduce that from
helium use will go from 71
days and we can extend the lifetime of
the cylinder
to over a year and this will reduce our
yearly cost to about 356 dollars
so the methods that get the the best
bang for the buck
with this is uh methods that use a split
flow
and high flows and then also those that
are
run not 24 7 but through a normal work
day
and maybe not over the weekend or
overnight
okay so what happens after we switch
from nitrogen in the sleep mode
going into helium and our run mode are
there any effects on the chromatography
going back and forth between the sleep
and wake cycles
so in this case i'm showing just some
chromatography so
in the upper chromatogram is my
reference run
so this is the original analysis using
helium carrier gas
that's run during the day and then
overnight we go into the sleep mode
where we're substituting nitrogen
allowing the system to be idle with
nitrogen flowing
and then we use the wake cycle to switch
back to helium
let it purge out for about a half an
hour and then we do our first run of the
day
and we can see that the chromatography
hasn't changed at all
so there really is no effect going from
the sleep awake cycles
as long as you've purged out the
nitrogen for an appropriate amount of
time
then finally we also see for the third
day again there's no
change in the chromatography
so this healing conservation approach
what are the benefits
the greatest impact as i said is with
split methods and for gc systems that
are not running
24 7 it's also
an advantage where you're not changing
anything in your methods so if you
can't change the methods or you don't
want to revalidate them
with an alternative carrier gas the
helium conservation approach
is probably the best uh a way to
reduce helium consumption also if you
use a lot of gcms methods
those are best run with helium and so
the helium conservation switch
and helium conservation approaches will
give you the optimum performance
when needed because you don't have to
change the carrier gas
okay so we've discussed in some detail
helium conservation and some of the ways
to
best use your helium resources if you
don't want to
change carrier gases however if you do
have the option of changing the carrier
gas
what are the best approaches to
alternatives so it will depend on
whether the instrument is
a gc or gcms if you have gcms
your real choice for an alternative
is only hydrogen nitrogen can't be used
it really
uh is not appropriate for mass spec
because it just
reduces the sensitivity for the mass
spec to the point of it being useless
however if you're using gc methods uh
you do have more options for
carrier gas not only nitrogen but there
are others but nitrogen as being the
most common
if your resolution is really sufficient
you have high resolution
then you could switch to a nitrogen
carrier gas
and give up some of the resolution that
you would typically get
with helium or with hydrogen nitrogen
will be perfectly suitable for that
if you are resolution critical however
your only real choice for gc methods
would be to
consider migrating to hydrogen carrier
gas
so we're going to discuss some of the
considerations
for both using hydrogen and nitrogen as
helium alternatives because before we
get into that
let's just take a look at these uh
two tables these are our
various carrier gases used with various
detectors
the most common carrier gases besides
helium
hydrogen nitrogen argon argon methane
hydrogen nitrogen being the most common
your detector that you're using can
influence your choice
so for instance if you are using a
thermal conductivity
detector oftentimes nitrogen is not the
best choice
because it has a high thermal
conductivity and it will reduce the
sensitivity looking for
things like hydrocarbons or other fixed
gases however
if you are using a tcd to
measure hydrogen or helium then nitrogen
actually
represents a good choice because there's
a large difference in thermal
conductivity
but that's kind of a corner case so uh
i'm just providing this for a reference
let's move on
now when considering conversion from
helium to hydrogen carrier gas
there are a number of aspects of our
methods that we have to take into
account
in general methods require less
optimization
when going to hydrogen carrier gas if
the analytes are durable
hydrogen is a reactive gas it's a
reducing gas
so those compounds that won't react with
hydrogen are best suited
also compounds that are at higher
concentrations
are also more suitable when using
hydrogen carrier gas
particularly with a mass spectrometer in
general
hygiene carrier gas will offer a little
less
sensitivity than helium with mass
spectrometers
also in general analytes that are used
with split injections
are more suitable with hydrogen carrier
gas particularly if those are
more reactive and that's because with
split injections
the residence time of the injection
is lower inside the inlet and so there's
less of a chance of reaction with
hydrogen carrier gas
with split injections also
compounds that have been derivatized to
improve their
gas chromatographic performance
will also be better suited for hydrogen
and that's because the functional groups
that are reactive
that cause poor chromatographic
performance
have been derivatized to make them
better chromatographic
compounds and those active sites
have been masked by the derivatization
compound
so they won't react with the hydrogen
methods that will generally require more
optimization
are of course the opposite any fragile
compounds will have first have to be
evaluated with hydrogen
to make sure that they aren't changed or
lost
in the presence of hydrogen also if
you're looking at the absolute lowest
trace level concentrations
you'll have to validate your method with
hydrogen first that you can
achieve those because as i said in
general
hydrogen is a less sensitive carrier gas
particularly for mass spec
operations before you complete your
change from helium to hydrogen you also
have to allow the necessary time
to update any sops and method validation
with the change in the carrier gas
now some considerations when switching
the hydrogen
you have to be aware of the flow
limitations due to the mass spec pumping
capacity
so oftentimes hydrogen is run at higher
flows
because you get better
performance chromatographic performance
so if you're going to use those higher
flows you have to make sure that your
mass spec
is has an adequate pumping system like a
turbo pump rather than a diffusion pump
to accommodate that higher flow
also there can be changes in peak
illusion order with the carrier gas
so you will have to revalidate those
peaks making sure they're identified
properly
and then you'll also have to consider
the column sample capacity
because that can change with the use of
a different carrier gas
as i said hydrogen is not an inert gas
it's a reducing gas
so it can react with the compounds that
you're trying to measure
so you also need to consider the full
inert flow path and we generally
recommend
to use inert columns we have ultra inert
columns and alternate flow paths
that may be more appropriate with
hydrogen carrier gas
you also want to use the lowest
temperatures possible
this particularly true of your inlets
and for instance
transfer lines with the mass spec again
higher temperatures will cause hydrogen
to be more reactive
and most importantly is you want to
avoid some solvents
particularly using split less injections
and hydrogen carrier gas
so those would be methylene chloride
carbon disulfide
that's because they have a long
resonance time and a high concentration
in the inlet at the time of injection
and they will react with the hydrogen
and they'll cause the formation of
hydrochloric acid and also sulfuric acid
and that will cause definite maintenance
issues with the inlet
and poor performance of a system
now before switching particularly those
you have older mass specs
the 5977 series is okay those are
completely proven
for hydrogen use some of the older 5975
systems however
do have source magnets that are not
compatible with hydrogen
the way you can tell that is you look at
the magnet and if it has a serial number
on it
then it is compatible with hygiene
carrier gas
if it does not have one do not use
hydrogen
if you do want to use it contact your
agilent service engineer
and there is a magnet that can be
swapped out
that will allow you to use hydrogen also
in the source we have lenses that are
optimized for better hydrogen use
and those are shown here so on the left
is the standard
three millimeter draw out plate that one
is
not the best for hydrogen we have a six
millimeter draw out plate
and then also now a nine millimeter
draw-out plate
that's been introduced for our various
sources those
are better uh used for hydrogen carrier
gas
so we would recommend converting that
source
lens when transferring from helium to
hydrogen
now when converting from helium to
hydrogen one really can't expect to
immediately start running samples
just by re-plumbing the carrier gas into
the instrument
there is going to be some initial setup
and some performance expectations
that will have to be dealt with
so after the switch to hydrogen you'll
notice initially that there's going to
be a high background
on your gcms signal when using a mass
spectrometer
if you look at the spectra of this
background it will look like
hydrocarbons
so there is going to be a startup
procedure that i'll discuss in a minute
or so
for cleaning out this background and
getting the
contamination removed as much as
possible from the system
there's also going to be a reduced
signal of noise with hydrogen carrier
gas
and that's because helium will give the
best signal to noise but because
of the ionization and the size of the
hydrogen
compared to helium you're not going to
get as efficient ionization
and so your minimal detective limits
will be lower
and then finally until the system is
conditioned
you're going to see significant hailing
if you
don't do that conditioning and in the
right hand chromatogram
you can see that in this case there's
some drugs of abuse that show extreme
tailing and particularly the cocaine
peak
so this is going to require some initial
startup to try to minimize these effects
now for any gc or gcms system there is
going to be a initial setup
and a cooperation time when switching
from helium to hydrogen carrier gas
and for gcms i'm listing some of those
steps here
so after you plumb in your hydrogen
carrier gas to your gc
you're going to allow the system to set
up overnight
to clean using the hydrogen carrier gas
so after doing the plumbing you'll pump
down the system
you'll set your source temperature to
the maximum temperature
for your particular source depending on
the mass spec that you're using
at the same time you're going to reduce
your electron multiplier voltage down to
800 volts
then you're going to run the system
overnight with the filaments turned on
and what this will do is this will
ionize the hydrogen coming into the
source
and this will allow the system to be
cleaned so you're going to run this
overnight
and then the next day come in and
do a matrix check to be sure that
everything looks okay
if it looks okay then you're ready to go
so this shows i uh the checkout
after doing the overnight cleanup with
hydrogen
and so we're going to compare the
results with the helium run
so after conversion from helium to
hydrogen we can see the chromatography
here
there is still somewhat some tailing
that can be expected depending on the
compounds
other compounds may not tail at all so
you can see
for instance that large peak at about
seven and a half minutes
there's not very much tailing at all and
in fact the response in hydrogen seems
to be better than in helium
however some of the other peaks are
showing some tailing and some reduced
response
and that's just the nature of using
hydrogen with a gcms system
so we have their conversion from helium
to hydrogen
what can you expect in your analytical
results on a gcms system
first the sensitivity can potentially be
reduced
on the order of two to five times
reduction in sensitivity
again hydrogen is a larger molecule and
it's easier
to ionize it than helium and so that is
going to reduce
some of the sensitivity in the source
some trace
reactive compounds may be lost
and you may not see them at all and then
also you can see that there could be
changes
in this actual mass spectra or the
spectral fidelity
so there could be some changes in the
observed ion ratios for some compounds
and there also could be missing or extra
ions and this will actually affect
uh your library searching so in this
example we show lindane
and you can see that in the upper
chromatogram with helium
uh the lower mass ions are somewhat
reduced
however if we look in the hydrogen
carrier gas
we're getting larger response for those
lower molecular weight ions and so this
will
affect the search so you can see in the
helium carrier gas
the search quality was 925
but with hydrogen it's been reduced
somewhat to 859
and then in the table on the right this
is a number of different
uh pesticides and you can see that the
difference in
this library match between helium and
hydrogen
does show somewhat of a difference and
you'll have to be prepared for that when
evaluating your result
now before getting into the details of
converting methods from helium to
hydrogen
i'm first going to have to discuss some
hydrogen safety features that are built
into the instrument
and then also some best practice
practices
for making the use of hydrogen as safe
as possible
we can provide for all of our agilent
gcs
a letter from agilent safety engineer
that describes the built-in features for
our instruments for using hydrogen in
the safest possible manner
these are available for our latest
instruments the 8890
8860 and also the intubo gc
in this slide we show some of the safety
features that are built into our
instruments that are described in the
letters
first of all we have a safety shutdown
so whenever
the gas pressure set points are not met
so this would be because of a leak or a
broken column
the valve and the heater are shut off so
the valve turns off
the hydrogen delivered from the epcs to
the instruments
and then the heaters are also
simultaneously shut off and this
prevents
any possible explosions that could take
place with buildup of hydrogen in the
instrument
we also have built into all of our epcs
that are hydrogen compatible a flow
limiting fret
so if the valve fails in any way
and stays in the open position these
frits
minimize the amount of hydrogen that can
be delivered
through the epc and into the instrument
also in our on off sequence for the oven
before the heaters are turned on when
turning the instrument on
the fan will come on and will purge the
oven
with multiple volumes of exchange of the
internal
gas chromatography oven to remove any
collected hydrogen
only after this has been run for a few
minutes
then the heaters will be turned on and
then finally we also do some
vigorous explosion tests for all our
instruments
where we put into the inside of the
instrument a lower explosive limit of
hydrogen we ignite that hydrogen
and then we make sure that if there is
an internal explosion
that no pieces come off of the
instrument
to be projectiles that could hurt or
injure
any laboratory personnel that are near
the instrument at the time of an
explosion
as a second level of safety we also
offer an optional
hydrogen sensor module this is
goes into the back of the gc it's
available for
a number of our more modern instruments
so show a
picture of it here it's a board that
goes into the back of the gc
and on the board is a long probe that
comes through
the back of the instrument and into the
actual calm oven
and this is a sniffer port so this
actually draws
the atmospheric gas inside the oven into
the
module or the hydrogen sensor module and
measures the amount of hydrogen that can
be detected
so the way this works is we install that
in the instrument
and then there's also comes with a
lecture bottle
of some hydrogen that's
at about 1 hydrogen in an inert gas
this can be used to calibrate the sensor
and you can also set up how often the
sensor becomes calibrated so this is
available
for uh our most modern instruments our
current instruments the 8890 and the
8860
and then also for some of the older
instruments
the 7090a plus so if you have 7890as
you could get this if you upgrade it to
an a plus
then all the 7090bs are also compatible
with the hydrogen sensor module
sources of hydrogen can be varied uh we
prefer or what we recommend are hydrogen
generators
we show the parker hydrogen generator
here
this generates hydrogen by filling it
with water
and it hydrolyzes the water to convert
it
to oxygen and hydrogen and then we'll
deliver that
to your gas chromatograph and you can
get these in various sizes to
accommodate different
maximum flows of hydrogen that required
for
multiple instruments for
hydrogen cylinder delivery we recommend
a clean gas filter there are third-party
devices that can be added to the
plumbing
outside of the gc that will shut off the
cylinders if there is a loss of pressure
or if a leak is detected we don't sell
those but
the environmental health and safety
officers
and for most companies know where to
acquire these
for many laboratories hygiene is
delivered from a common source
throughout the building
and so of course the local
building maintenance people
environmental health and safety people
typically do a routine hydrogen safety
check
now when plumbing your gc 2 whatever
hydrogen source you're using
we're recommending to use really good
quality stainless steel tubing
we also say don't use older tubing these
can be contaminated
just by sitting around the laboratory
and hydrogen is known as a scrubbing gas
and what you'll see is a high background
so use
new stainless steel tubing or tubing
that's been
thermally cleaned we don't recommend
using
copper tubing especially old copper
tubing copper does become brittle over
time
there's also some indication that
hydrogen flowing through copper tubing
accelerates the brittleness and so this
can cause
breaks in the tubing and leaks and
delivery of hydrogen where you don't
want it
for your split vents you want to make
sure that your split vents are connected
to an exhaust because you are going to
be putting
sometimes high flows of hydrogen out
into the laboratory atmosphere so you
don't
want to let those set off any alarms and
then also when you're plumbing up a new
system or making any changes to your
instrument
you want to be sure that you check for
leaks we don't really recommend
snoop especially because
it is a surfactant
and if that gets into your flow path it
can cause contamination problems
so we really do recommend using a leak
checker
we have one they are more expensive but
they work extremely well
and they're very good for detecting
hydrogen leaks
now when converting methods from helium
to an alternative carrier gas
these are just some bullet points here
we want to make sure we
follow all the safety protocols and
recommendations for your facility
so you want to start when converting
from helium to an alternative you want
to start with an existing helium method
it's easier than trying to create an
entirely new method with a new carrier
gas
then we provide a software tool called
method translation software
to help you make that transition
to the alternative carrier gas from an
existing helium method
so method translation software assumes
that you're using the same
column both the column phase and the
dimensions of the column
and then when you do your conversion
from helium to hydrogen
or even to nitrogen method translation
software we assure
that you have the same peak order and
retention time for your new operating
conditions with the alternative carrier
gas
so after you do that conversion you want
to make sure that you use the software
to check to make sure your gc can meet
the new method conditions
for instance column head pressure and
then also
when you're translating a hydrogen
method
once you validate that then you want to
only then go through and explore some
possible speed improvements
because hydrogen carrier gas does
typically work at its optimal mode
at higher flows than helium and so
you could potentially get an improvement
in speed
for your methods without any loss of
resolution
now as an example of using the method
translation software
i'm showing it here with a astm method
d5769 this method is
a gcms method that is used
to measure aromatics in gasoline
so i'm interested in taking my
helium 5769 method and converting it to
hydrogen so in this case i'm showing a
screenshot
of the method translation software
so under the original method parameters
we enter in
all the column dimensions of the flow
that we're using
and the temperature program and then in
the calculated method parameters we make
sure that
the column dimensions are maintained
they're the same as the original method
and then we go over to the speed gain
in the upper left hand corner and for a
symbol conversion we're going to
do a speed gate of 1 so this will make
sure that the
retention times and the peak allusion
order
once we convert to hydrogen are
maintained and then finally
we go over into our calculated method
and we make sure that hydrogen is
selected
what the method translation software
will do is it will
then calculate a new head pressure and
a new flow for the instrument
using the hydrogen carrier gas so we do
maintain
our pollution order and retention times
so we can see the effect of a
translation of 5769
so in the upper chromatogram i have my
helium carrier gas this is a
calibration standard and if we look at
the retention times we can see that the
run goes from with peaks from about six
minutes out to
just under 30 minutes then after i've
used the method translation software
to go from helium to hydrogen you can
see that there's
almost no change in retention time a
very minimal change in the retention
times
and then also uh the resolution
well it's about the same and there's no
changing of the peak aleutian order
and so what this allows us to do is uh
have minimal changes to the method
because we're measuring all these
compounds we want to make sure that our
integration parameters and our
peak identification and quantification
parameters
remain the same and so this will help
with setting up the method
for going from helium to hydrogen
carrier gas
then this is an example of after the
conversion running
a sample so this is an actual gasoline
sample
that was used in a proficiency testing
program
so the upper chromatogram shows the
helium carrier
result and the bottom shows the hygiene
carrier result
you can see that pretty much they look
the same
the hydrogen looks a little busier
but if we look at the results
and that's shown in this slide uh the
results between the helium
and the hydrogen carrier gas are nearly
identical
so for our benzene tylene result
0.23 volume percent of benzene
0.3 for helium
and pretty much the same for hydrogen
carrier gas for the total aromatics
we have about 19.65 with helium
and 19.68 for hydrogen and those match
well with the consensus values
that other laboratories have determined
for this particular sample
now of course besides helium and
hydrogen
nitrogen is another carrier gas that can
be used
and serves as a potentially good
alternative
to helium if we're trying to save helium
a number of methods that are used in
chemical and energy or what we used to
call
hydrocarbon processing industry are well
suited to nitrogen
things like simulated distillation where
absolute resolution isn't required
a nitrogen may be a very good choice as
an alternative
to helium some of the advantages of
nitrogen
it's readily available and it's less
expensive
so you can find it in good
chromatographic grades pretty much
anywhere in the world
aside from using pressurized gas
cylinders there's no other safety
concerns with nitrogen
as there would be with hydrogen because
it's it's not a reactive or
explosive gas uh it's really
very suitable for simple routine
analysis
where you have more than enough
resolution
and then nitrogen is also suitable for
some 2d gc techniques
these would be where we're using two
different columns to optimize resolution
so we're using the column to give us the
best resolution
and so the nitrogen may be a good
carrier guess for this
these are typically for pack columns
using valves where we're using multiple
columns and valves
to tweak a separation however for
the more sophisticated 2d check
2d technique techniques like gcgc
nitrogen is not really a suitable
carrier gas
some potential issues for nitrogen there
are reduced chromatographic
resolution at higher flows at the flows
that we're typically used to using with
helium
so you won't get the same resolution and
again it can't really be used with gcms
and some other gc detectors because of
loss of sensitivity
so when trying to convert from helium to
an alternative carrier guess
we're going to take an easy approach as
i described earlier we're going to take
an existing helium method and we can use
some of the firmware
in the gc system to make this conversion
easy even without using method
translation software
so the goal here is to change the
carrier gas
while keeping all the other method
conditions exactly the same so we're
going to use the same column
the same oven program and we're going to
adjust
the flow or the hold up time so that we
maintain the same peak aleutian order
and keep the retention times of the
peaks as close to the original value
with the alternative carrier gas as we
observe with
helium carrier gas this makes
our validation easier because there's
minimum changes
to integration events and also the peak
identification tables
if the aleutian order and the retention
times don't change
significantly with a change in carrier
gas
if you're using a nitrogen as the
alternative
you do want to test the resolution of
key components
make sure that those are still
sufficient enough to
be able to separate and quantify those
components
and we can use the tools directly built
into the firmware
or into our chromatography data systems
to guide through the process
now i'm showing here the uh the van
diemer curve and
i'm going to specifically be talking
about nitrogen as it relates to the
venting there
so i'm calling it the tyranny of
andinter from a nitrogen standpoint
we've done a very good job over the last
40 or 50 years
with capillary chromatographers of
convincing them that nitrogen is not an
appropriate gas
for capillary gc and we use the van
dimter curve
to do that so in this case we're doing a
separation
we can see here on the the right of
a couple of components with nitrogen
helium and hydrogen all operating
at a linear velocity of about 58
centimeters per second
with the corresponding flows shown here
and then what we are measuring is the
resolution and if
you look at this you'd say oh well
nitrogen is a terrible carrier gas
because
it doesn't provide any resolution at all
however we're looking at it
the nitrogen at a high flow rate if you
actually look at the van diemer curve
nitrogen potentially is the best carrier
gas for
resolution and that's because what we're
looking for
is to try to go maintain our system at
the minimum
of the van diemer curve where the
efficiency uh
is uh is the best and you can see that
nitrogen
actually has a lower height equivalent
of theoretical plate
and so this has the the best resolution
potentially the best resolution
and the the best efficiency
unfortunately that happens at a lower
speed you can see the linear velocity
where this occurs
is somewhere around 10 centimeters a
second
so what happens is people don't really
consider nitrogen because they don't
want to
wait for two or three times longer to
get their results
however most gcs use constant flow mode
and so with changes in flow due to
changes in temperature
those are not observed as they were in
the past before
programmable epcs
okay so to demonstrate converting a
helium method
to nitrogen or to hydrogen
using the simplest process possible i'm
looking here at a test case
this is again another astm method it's
the 6584.
it's used to measure contaminants in
biodiesel specifically mono
dye and triglycerides and also
glycerol so i'm showing the instrument
conditions here
so the astm method uses helium carrier
gas
at three mils a minute and the
uh to run in the constant pressure mode
at about 7.63
psi on the inlet and this just shows the
region where the peaks of interest are
alluding
now the first step when changing from
helium to
either hydrogen or nitrogen is of course
to plumb the carrier gas to the
instrument
then we have to tell the instrument that
we have made
a carrier gas change so to do this you
go into the configuration
screen for your particular gc go to the
inlet where you change the carrier gas
and select the appropriate gas
so in this case we have a coupon column
inlet that we're going to change
and we go from helium to hydrogen or
nitrogen
after making that change go over and
look at the column section and look at
the flow so as i said
this method uses three mls a minute of
flow but we also want to look at the
holdout time
so with helium carrier gas
the hold up time is 0.47
minutes at a 3 mm minute flow
so do i want to maintain the same flow
with my alternative carrier gas or do i
want to maintain the same
hold up time let's see what the
difference is
so in this case i'm showing the same run
we're going to be looking here at the
monoglyceride aleutian area
and this shows in the upper chromatogram
helium
at a flow of 3 mils a minute this is the
7.63 psi
and the hold up time is 0.47
now if i maintain the same flow with
hydrogen or
with nitrogen you can see that the
flows are the same but the hold up times
are different
so for hydrogen the hold up time is now
0.42 which
is a little faster and then for nitrogen
it is 0.46 which again is
faster still and you can see that result
here
is that the hydrogen peaks are alluding
faster
than the helium and then in nitrogen
they're alluding
a little bit faster than the helium but
not quite as fast as the hydrogen
but the point to note here is the peaks
are not
at the same retention time and what we
really want to do is maintain them
as close to the original retention time
as helium
as possible so instead of maintaining
the same flow
when changing carrier gas
let's maintain the same hold up time
so in this slide we're looking at the
hold up time
is being maintained with the different
carrier gases
so it's the 0.472 minutes and you can
see now the peaks line up much better
and so this will save us from having to
do a lot of changes to integration
parameters
and to the calibration table for
quantifying
these peaks now let's take a look at
some of the resolution
and you'll note that in the hydrogen
some of the peaks have better resolution
so those eluding at about roughly 18 and
a half minutes
you can see that the resolution for
those two pairs that aren't quite based
on resolved
are better with hydrogen but if we look
at nitrogen you can see that the
resolution is entirely lost
and so in this case if we were
interested in maintaining that
resolution
then nitrogen would not be the best
carrier gas of choice
as an alternative hydrogen would be
now if we look at what we're actually
doing with this analysis
is we're reporting as an aggregate uh
the monoglycerides so in this case
uh the resolution of that pair
is not really important is because we we
integrate them and report them together
so in this example we could use
nitrogen as a carrier gas because even
though we've lost resolution
it doesn't really affect the overall
results because we would have integrated
those together
anyway and we're not really looking for
a complete resolution
again this has to be a judgment that you
make
is the carrier guest delivering for you
the resolution that's required by your
analysis
so those results are shown here so no
matter what carrier guess we use
we're getting the same result for all of
our different classes of compounds with
the sample
so in this case i would say either
hydrogen or nitrogen would be an
appropriate carrier gas to use
for this particular method because this
doesn't really affect the overall
results on the chromatography
required by this method
so in summary i've shown that
we can easily migrate your gc method
conditions
from a helium carrier gas so
for methods where resolution is
absolutely critical
hydrogen will offer the best alternative
and also for gcms methods hydrogen will
be the best alternative
for many gc applications nitrogen
can be used it offers a cheap and easy
alternative without the safety
worries that can sometimes accompany
hydrogen
most existing helium methods do have too
much resolution
so a change in nitrogen even at the same
analysis speeds
uh generally won't affect that if again
you have sufficient resolution
nitrogen can be used without changing
any of the existing gc conditions
as long as you keep the hold up time the
same
and not try to match the flow and then
2d
methods particularly those with paccoms
and valves
are ideally suited than nitrogen however
gcgc or comprehensive gc are not really
suited for nitrogen
and then as i discussed at the top of
the presentation
if helium alternative is not an option
if you really don't want to change to
another carrier guess
because you don't want to change your
sops or have to revalidate your methods
we do offer an approach to using hij
or using helium with the conservation
features built into the instrument
so you can combine the gas saver mode
for your split split list or mi
inlets with the new second generation
helium conservation switch and
potentially this can save you
up to 10 times in helium costs again
depending on the operating conditions
and how many samples you're running
with your instrument during the day so
with that i'd like to thank you for
participating in our seminar i hope you
found this information
useful and interesting and i hope to see
you again
at some other agilent presentations and
again thanks for participating
from agilent technologies